-Welcome back, everybody. I'm
hanging out with Demi Lovato.
Now, Demi --
New album this Friday.
"Holy F."
We always have fun
when you're on the show,
so I wanted to play
a new game with you.
This is called "Quicktionary."
Here we go.
-♪ It's Quick...tionary ♪
-Now, here's how it works.
We each have a stack of cards
with clues on them, okay?
We're going to take turns
picking a card,
and then we're gonna
have to draw whatever clue
is on the card, but we'll only
have 10 seconds to draw.
So you got to be quick. Okay?
-Okay.
-And then, after that,
the drawing will come up
on the screen behind us,
and the other person
will have 10 seconds
to guess what that is.
Quicktionary. Here we go.
For round one,
the category is songs.
-Okay.
-Yeah.
What song you thinking of --
Before we even see the clue?
What song do you think it is?
-What?!
-No, I'm just kidding.
-Alright. That's a psychic game.
We'll play that next time.
-Okay.
-You're our guest.
Alright. That's the clue.
Don't show me. Look at the clue.
When you're ready, say, "I'm
ready," and then start drawing.
And you have 10 seconds.
-These are songs? Okay.
-Yeah. It's just one song.
Yeah.
-Okay.
-Yep.
10 seconds. Wow.
-Oh, 10 seconds.
I'm so -- Wait.
-No, it's happening.
It's 5 seconds now. Four...
Alright, we're getting
close to the end, there.
[ Buzzer ]
Okay.
-Aah!
-No.
That's good.
Let's see what you drew.
And I have 10 seconds to guess.
Here we go.
[ Laughter ]
-First block. First square.
First -- One Direction? No.
First base. First --
That's not a song.
"First Class."
-Yes!
-Wow.
-Yes! Yes!
I did not know
what to draw there.
-I don't think you can
write the word "first,"
but I could be wrong.
That kind of feels like
cheating to me.
-Now that you say it out loud.
-Yeah, you go, "Oh."
You just wrote "First Class."
Awesome. Good clues.
"How did I guess that one,
Jimmy? Oh, my gosh."
"Well, I wrote 'First Class.'"
Here we go. Songs.
-Okay. Songs.
-Yeah, you got this.
-I got this.
-Alright.
Do I have to look away?
-No, you don't, but I'm ready.
Go.
♪♪
[ Buzzer ]
-Okay.
-Let's see what I drew.
[ Laughter ]
Love house.
Love...home.
Love -- Heart.
Love...
[ Buzzer ]
Shack!
-Yes!
Come on! We got...
[ Cheers and applause ]
I could have drawn
Shaquille O'Neal,
but I'm not that talented.
But -- Okay. Your turn.
-Okay.
-Alright.
Now, this one is TV shows.
-Okay.
-TV show. I'm not looking.
But we got this.
Come on.
Partner, we've done this --
A thousand times, we've played.
Oh, you're going. Oh, sorry.
No, that's good. You're right.
-Okay.
-Yeah.
TV shows.
[ Buzzer ]
Okay. Okay.
Let's see what you did.
[ Laughter ]
Winnie the Pooh?
-It's -- No.
-"The Bear."
♪♪
Bear...Grylls? No.
[ Bell dinging ]
Bear -- Bear --
-Yes!
-Yes?
-Bear...
-Yay! "The Bear."
-"The Bear."
Oh, yeah! "The Bear." We got it.
[ Dinging ]
Okay. Here we go.
Ready for this?
-Yeah.
-Gosh.
[ Breathes deeply ]
Okay.
♪♪
[ Buzzer ]
That was 10 seconds?
Alright. Let's see what I drew.
-Okay.
Oh. Candles? Cake?
Birthday cake? The cake.
The candles.
What?
Ohh...
[ Buzzer ]
Blowing out candles.
-No.
[ Laughter ]
You said it was cake.
-Yes.
-But...
-Whose cake.
-Not --
"Whose Cake?" is not a show.
"Whose Cake?" isn't...
"Is It Cake?"
-"Is It Cake?"
-"Is It Cake?" is a show.
-Okay.
-Alright. Here we go.
The last one, we're going to
do this together, okay?
-Okay.
-Take this. That's for you.
-This is for me, here.
We're gonna do this together.
The category is
popular sayings, okay?
We're going to both write
on our iPads.
It will go on the same screen.
And we're going to have to
get Questlove to guess.
-[ Inhales sharply ]
Ah. Okay.
-And if he gets this right,
we're BFFs forever.
-And this is the hint?
-This is the hint.
This is it.
-Okay. Okay.
-It's not even the hint.
This is it.
-This is it.
Well, yes, this is --
-Are you ready?
-Yes.
[ Laughs ]
-Ooh!
-Oh, it's a popular saying.
♪♪
[ Buzzer ]
Whew.
-Wow.
-Nailed it.
-Yeah.
-You.
-Thank you.
You did, too.
Yours was in the action of it.
So that was better.
-Alright. Here we go.
Quest, come on, bud.
This is for all the money.
-Oh, boy. Oh, my God!
[ Laughter ]
Is that a bleeding heart?
-No.
[ Laughter ]
-Is that a puppy?
-Five seconds.
It's not a puppy.
-Is that an axe?
-Keep saying stuff.
-No!
-Flag.
-No.
-Mongoose.
[ Buzzer ]
Wait a minute!
Ten seconds is too short.
-A mongoose?
Where do you see mongoose?
-I don't know.
It looks like --
-That is fantastic.
Good job on your part.
That is clearly a tea bag.
Now do you guess it?
-Tea bag -- No.
Oh, uh, uh, it's a saying.
A cup of tea. A spot of tea.
Oh, spill the tea!
-Yes!
-There we go. Yay!
-I'm gonna take that.
Demi Lovato, everybody.
Demi's "Holy F" tour
is going on through this fall.
Their album is out this Friday!
When we come back, we're talking
with Murray Bartlett.
Stick around, everybody.
This Friday! Come on!